oui drôle d'anniversaire en tout cas
drôle d'ambiance et drôle de soirée à la
télévision est-allemand car les
allemands de l'est depuis longtemps
s'informent par le biais des télévisions
ouest allemandes se sont ils ont droit
sur leur programme officiel à la
célébration un peu pesante des
réalisations du socialisme et les
commentateurs officiels insiste aussi
sur le chômage et la criminalité à
l'ouest mais au même moment en ce moment
même les journaux télévisés
ouest-allemand leur montre quoi et bien
encore des images de gens qui suit de
réfugiés à prague en hongrie à varsovie
est ici à berlin ces réfugiés ce ne sont
pas des étrangers ce ne sont pas des
inconnus on les aime on les attend
souvent depuis longtemps on les espère
car ils sont de la famille corinne
pertuis et jean-françois hoffman en sont
témoins
l'avion de nürnberg est en retard encore
10 minutes à patienter ce n'est rien et
c'est beaucoup certains attendent leur
frère ou leur mari depuis quelques jours
où depuis plusieurs années un coup de
fil leur a appris ce matin que ceux qui
espèrent retrouver depuis si longtemps
font partie de les fusils de l'ambassade
d'allemagne fédérale à prague les
premiers commencent à arriver
à
enfin grâce avec sa femme ses deux
enfants retrouve ses parents il y à un
encore toute la famille habitait berlin
est mais les grands parents sont passés
à l'ouest avec un visa de tourisme 10
sont restés aujourd'hui la famille est à
nouveau réunie après six jours d'un
voyage éprouvant avec mardi on a pensé
que c'était la fin de mon en poème lu
dans les mairies on était dans une
chambre sans être une fête et terry
vraiment terrible
pour vivre cet instant ils ont tout
essayé la frontière polonaise passer
illégalement ce n'était pas possible
alors apprenant que c'était plus facile
par la tchécoslovaquie ils sont partis
pour prague après quatre jours à
l'ambassade
on les a accueillis à auf den nurenberg
ils se sont envolés pour berlin ils ont
fait plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
pour se retrouver à quelques mètres
seulement de leur point de départ du
marin demain ils iront s'inscrire
officiellement ils passeront quelques
jours dans un camp de réfugiés avant
d'avoir un appartement mais pour le
premier soir à l'ouest ils vont se
serrer un peu dans l'appartement des
camps parents me
demandent si je regrette d'être venu ici
j'aurais pas une seule chose le seul
regret que c'est de notre pas pensé dawn
run de lost vingt ans plus tôt
aujourd'hui pour hans monica daniel et
stéphane une nouvelle vie commence
ils vont devoir apprendre les règles du
jeu en vigueur de ce côté ci du mur ils
sont désormais citoyen d'allemagne de
l'ouest
le seigneur vous voici maintenant avec
vos deux enfants ici philippe ans ici au
pied du mur que vous avez mis si
longtemps à franchir quel effet ça vous
fait de le vent de ce côté ci
je dois vous dire que la vie y est tout
à fait différente ici
nous sommes maintenant à berlin ouest à
le voyage est extrêmement long elle a
été très pénible
j'ai voyagé avec d'autres personnes j'ai
lié connaissance avec des gens
et maintenant je me retrouve directement
devant le mur je ne suis pas habitué
parce que moi je ne connais ce mur que
de l'autre côté et de le côté il y à la
police il y a les gardes
alors je vois le mur mais ça me fait
encore une impression un peu curieuse
et les policiers pendant le monde nous
observe en ce moment mais le mur le mur
il faut que le dire ici c'est une
blessure c'est une obsession c'est une
habitude aussi c'est en 1961 que le
régime est-allemand la i10 y est pour
mieux s'épanouir et pour le fuir des
gens sont morts ici jérôme boni